josée legault michel david hâle tirage
bonsoir bonsoir une hostie alors
évidemment un ministre qui dépose un
projet de loi la tendance c'est à dire
historique et c'est bon c'est vrai qu'on
la change pas on la modifie pas souvent
cette loi sur les langues officielles au
pays
tour d'horizon d'abord tour de table sur
qu'est-ce que la dent est ce que ça va
parce que l'objectif est de mieux
protéger le français que l'on pour la
première fois comme dit la mine est
jolie avant la pause où on reconnaît que
le français est pas du tout dans la même
situation que les anglais au pays et que
on reconnaît que le français la langue
officielle du québec etc
josée legault est ce que ça va changer
quelque chose ce que bouger vous y voyez
un changement de politique d'attitude
important mais j'y vois un changement de
culture politique quand même assez assez
majeur bon on verra évidemment lorsque
la loi sera de fait les moyens est ce
qu'ils y seront mais écoutez le
gouvernement trudeau s'éloigne carré mal
de la doctrine de trudeau père de cette
loi qui conférait aux à l'anglais au
prince est au canada un statut d'égalité
évidemment citer ces petits luzoir
d'état mêmes mensonges et les deux
langues n'ont jamais été égal et là le
gouvernement de justin trudeau le
reconnaît dans ce projet de loi qu'il ya
inégalité de voiliers de pouvoir etc
et il reconnaît même une territorialité
en reconnaissant que le français est la
langue officielle du québec
bon avec toutes les nuances la dde aussi
c'est très dur envers la minorité alors
écoutez c'est vraiment un changement de
culture politique majeure ouais c'est 2
c'est pas parce que on dessin vous dites
c'est irréel sur ces entrefaites à tout
le moins de passagers la michel david
on revient dans une certaine rayter d'un
cadet communauté des nations
quand une nation québécoise qui parlent
le français c'est sa langue officielle
c'est un changement pour employer un mot
qui est à la mode son changement de
paradigme quand m oui c'est un
changement au plan philosophique en tout
cas il est clair que jusqu'à présent il
y avait deux filles et aux jo deux
langues officielles d'ailleurs j'imagine
qu'il ya des avocats qui vont s'amuser
avec ça si on dit qu'il ya deux langues
officielles non au québec il y en a
juste une se comprend bien
du point de vue fédéral ce que québec a
toujours affirmé que le gouvernement
fédéral ne reconnaissait pas plus comme
comme disait josé le principe de la
symétrie entre entre les deux langues au
canada tout ça sur le plan philosophique
il ya un progrès qui en fait une
reconnaissance de la réalité
mais au plan pratique c'est là qu'on va
voir un usage parce que la garantie de
services en français par exemple pour
les francophones hors québec ali dans la
loi depuis 1969 et on sait que dans la
réalité c'est pour ce qui se passe tous
les commissaire aux langues officielles
les uns après les autres ont dénoncé le
manque de vigueur de volonté de mettre
les dispositions de la loi en
application le dernier comme celle du
thé vert jeudi exactement la même chose
dans son dernier rapport
alors c'est faux parce qu'une loi le dit
que ça se transpose nécessairement
résultats sur le terrain alors ça il
faudra voir mais disons que l'intention
aller il est indiscutablement louable
les francophones l'association des
francophones hors et hors québec je
cherche la citation la fédération je
vais parce que je la cherche je ne la
trouvais pas je vais la trouver un jour
applaudi les anglophones au québec
disant attention les dangers al tirage
comment vous avez
vous je dépends du projet de loi ben je
pense que le des poutres phrasé loi
c'est stratégiquement déployés
aujourd'hui parce que l'économie
libérale voulait qu'on parle du projet
de loi et non de la motion du bloc
québécois
mais si on met de côté le projet de loi
je suis d'accord avec josé c est un
changement complet c'est une loi qui est
très ambitieuse aussi une loi qui donne
plus de pouvoir aux commissaires les
mesures qu'ils ont rapport avec les
entreprises fédérales à l'extérieur du
québec qui doivent maintenant c'est se
dire ces nouvelles lois ou à ce que les
employés vont pouvoir travailler en
français c'est quand même très ambitieux
même si ça se fait sur un plan de cinq
ans ce serait un très gros changement si
ce projet de loi est adopté
bombay pardon parlons-en de cet aspect
là je ne sais pas si on peut mettre
l'extrait de jaune et barrett avant du
ministre québécois il dit moi bravo si
vous voulez sommet nous c'est notre loi
la loi 100 qui doit s'appliquer aux
entreprises sous juridiction fédérale
mais la ministre vient de nous dire moi
je vais pas mostyn et je veux avoir un
objectif qui doit plus de français dans
ces lieux là on écoute le ministre on
revient et modalités associés au projet
de loi québécoise seront celles qui vont
s'appliquer sur le territoire québécois
et c'est la responsabilité du
gouvernement du québec de protéger le
français
alors on it war attrayant collaboration
entre le fédéral mais en s'assurant que
c'est la loi québécoise qui s'applique
mais c'est pas compliqué en eau
juridiction en matière d'entreprises
fédéral c'est écrit dans la constitution
donc qu'est ce qu'on veut faire est-ce
qu'on veut protéger le français où on
veut ce style et moi je veux juste
protéger le français
josé d'écouté c'est l usure qu'on va le
voir mais sur le plan politique
évidemment on est en période
préélectorale au fédéral on ne sait pas
quelles élections vont avoir lieu mais
on sait qu'il va avoir lieu
éventuellement et là évidemment se
faisait à tout ce discours là sur qui
doit s'occuper des ddd compagnie
fédérale au québec
le message principal je pense que
tentent d'envoyer le gouvernement
trudeau
face au bloc québécois bien entendu mais
aussi aux gouvernements legault s'est
écouté tout confiance on va s'en occuper
les choses vont changer on va mieux
protéger le procès est évidemment de son
côté c'est mon chalet barrette doit
affirmer lui aussi son pouvoir de
contrôle
mais dans les faits je pense que ce qui
va surtout être captées dans l'opinion
publique
c'est que il ya un changement majeur qui
vient de se produire à table ok je vous
fais entendre l'opposition à ottawa pas
c'est intéressant parce que sur le fond
que vous allez monsieur blanchet
notamment écouter ça qu'on revient vers
le mans ça c'est clair pour une loi qui
n'est qu'ils aient déposé qui n'est
qu'une opération de relations publiques
parce que on sait tous que la fin de
session arriver que le gouvernement
libéral veut alors d'élections dès
l'automne donc les libéraux le savent
comme tous les députés à la chambre des
communes que ce projet doit n'auront
aucune chance de voir le jour
on est le 15 juin le 15 juin par le fn
d'un séjour
elle sait que son prochain doit à aucune
chance d'être adoptée puis avocat même
de l'avant censé faire de la petite
politique sur le dos des francophones à
travers le pays c'est du cynisme libéral
à son meilleur salaire aucun sérieux
sa note énoncés à caractère politique à
la proche d'un possible enjeu électoral
ou d'un poids si possible échéances
électorales parce qu'il ne se passera
rien d'autre avec ce document là que
d'être déposée faire un peu de buzz sur
son essence mais il repas de il y aura
pas d'étude en chambre
je vous rappelle que mercredi prochain
on ferme les livres c'est sans parler
que le sénat impôts toujours
singulièrement ouvert
et monsieur blanchet cas ajouté et s'ils
reviennent il dit dieu m'en garde ou
pouvoir majoritaire
si on ne se repose ce projet de loi là
la ministre a dit que ce serait le même
alors le relais dans la joute politique
du chef david ces clubs laisse pas sur
le fond qui sont à l'essai sur le moment
oui parce que sur le fond c'est
difficile d'attaquer centre que
certainement pour le bloc mais une
manoeuvre électorale bien entendu on te
réveilles d'une élection
le message est limpide si vous voulez
que ce projet de loi lot devienne loi
révisée nous parce que si les
conservateurs sont élus on n'est pas sûr
que ça va être le même projet de loi
alors c'est limpide
c'est même pas subtilior on peut appeler
ça un chantage du clientèle de saper ça
comme vous voulez c'est ça le message ou
plus ou plutôt un humain on peut a fait
ça parce que sur le fond il ya pas de
quoi même quand je disais les
communautés anglophones au québec que ce
soit un peu inquiété je lisais ça mais
il n'y a pas de quoi fouetter un chat
non plus on dit faut mieux protéger les
français qui sont en situation
minoritaire ailleurs qu'au québec au
québec mais il faut reconnaître que le
français c'est le foyer du français
c'est tout ouais mais il ya aussi quand
même je dirais des choses qu'ils ont qui
vont peut-être donné rastrelli
communauté anglophone au québec dans le
sens que le gouvernement promet que
des indications la petite enfance
jusqu'à l'université on pourra la faire
dans la langue de notre choix en anglais
donc et puis que le gouvernement
réaffirme qu'ils vont investir dans le
programme de contestation judiciaire
quelque chose aussi qu'ils ont souligné
pour la communauté anglophone sur la
stratégie électorale
évidemment les politiciens forme de la
politique je dirais que c'est possible
du chantage préélectorale je pense que
le parti libéral avait un devoir de
mettre ce projet de loi de l'avant ça
fait quand même six ans qu'on en parle
on avait promis dans le discours du
trône à l'automne dernier alors c'est
comme ça
ignorant de leur part de ne pas l'avoir
mis de l'avant avant potentiellement des
élections je vous rappelle qu'on n'a pas
besoin d'aller en élection il est ce que
c'est pas ce soir à 18h30 oui c'est vrai
et du jour à la chambre des communes qui
permet aux députés qu'ils ne se
représenteraient pas de faire leurs
adieux on a quand même eu ni ce soit
pour vous ce n'est pas la preuve
étincelant qu'il y aura une campagne
septembre mais le gouvernement veut
vraiment aller en élection c'est vrai et
tous les partis planifie pour avoir des
élections à la fin de ce mois d'août
mais sauf s'il y avait une quatrième
vague et voilà on rappelle que au mois
de janvier on pensait qu'elle à avoir
des élections au printemps puis la
troisième vague puis appuyez d'élections
alors si un malheur et on rentre dans
une quatrième vague fort probable qu'on
va pas avoir d'élections à l'automne
dernier mais quand même jour à je vous
rappellerai que madame joly non-vote
entrevue avec vous ni pour vous dire non
non il n'y aurait pas avoir d'élections
un projet de loi qu'il redéposerait
reviennent au pouvoir et elle a promis
de le ré du projet intégralement la qui
aurait pas de changement d'échelle
devait de rire même un petit mot sur qui
je vois arriver à voix josé premier
après sur cette permission qu'on a donné
aux députés de faire leurs adieux
si jamais il devait pas avoir une autre
une autre session du parlement à
l'automne polichinelle que tout le monde
veut aller en élections afin surtout le
gouvernement 10 ans et que sauf comme
comme dit tiens oui ce qu'ils ont à dire
il va y avoir c'est pas de troisième de
quatrième vague il y aura des élections
et comme on se disait la semaine
dernière au gouvernement même pas besoin
de prétexte pour aller en élections les
jeunes ou voit que c'est la fin normale
d'un gouvernement minoritaire alors à
moins de quelque chose d'extraordinaire
et plus haut possible en politique il y
aura élection
vos propos ont été entendus d'ailleurs
dans les capitales chez quand j'avais 10
ans la semaine dernière très clairement
genre essayer même pas d'élaborer un
scénario trop compliqué pour dire que
vous êtes bloqué vous aller en élections
d'aller en élections après deux ans les
gens s'y attend tellement josée legault
vous avez j'ai entendu réagir à moins
qu'une résurgence de quoi évidemment
mais oui parce qu'on est encore en
pandémie
donc on est loin d'avoir terminé la
vaccination deuxième dose et cetera donc
il a de plus en plus d'experts part de
la possibilité d'une quatrième vague à
l'automne
donc c'est sûr qui reprend des élections
sont un quatrième vague si on a la part
belle aux probablement des élections moi
ce que je trouve aussi fascinant dans
tout ce qui se passe aujourd'hui et
c'est la réaction aussi du québec umq
minetti du québec qui veut les technos
c'est toi qui le lober anglo québécois
locke & key le descendant d'alliance
québec plaisent en colère contre le
projet de loi de mélanie joly c'est une
attaque clair contre l'égalité des
langues officielles
et en effet on y reconnaît une asymétrie
alors imaginez si le gouvernement
trudeau est réélu et majoritaire
il passe sa loi tel que parce que je
pense qu'il faut croire cet engagement
là il va y avoir des contestations
devant des tribunaux de cette loi là
parce qu'il n'y a pas de clause
dérogatoire leur cette fois-ci et elles
vont probablement même isolation bas
venir de la communauté anglo québécoise
conquête gouvernement trudeau alors
là on aurait sauté du rôle historique à
l'ironie historique
ça ressemble d'ailleurs à ce qui s'était
passé souvenez vous allez à l'époque de
meech le gouvernement chrétien maronite
juges avaient accepté d'inscrire dans
l'accord du lac meech que nonobstant le
tout cette société distincte et c'est le
gouvernement fédéral c'était le sens du
rapport charest conserver le droit et le
devoir de soutenir la minorité
anglophone au québec francophone
d'ailleurs bien sûr et même ça ça
n'avait pas rassuré ceux qui voyaient
dans la société distincte là un sombre
complot pour pour enlever des droits aux
anglophones alors ça me surprend pas
cette réaction là donc allez vous êtes
vous surprise parce qu'effectivement le
combat comme le tigre oups nature dit
que c'est ni plus ni moins une attaque
l'air toute légalité des langues
officielles du canada etc
ouais est sur le point d josé c'est à
cause que c'est une asymétrie qui a été
reconnue mais ils sont
ils sont très inquiets des mesures du
travail et beaucoup de gens qui pensent
que bon ben ça veut dire que la petite
entreprise familiale où est ce que oui
plus de vingt-cinq gens qui y
travaillent mais c'est des gens qui
travaillent à temps partiel
peut-être que steven grandir il va
falloir qu'ils déménagent à toronto ou
que la plupart des gens travaillent de
la maison commence que ça va se passer
que la communauté n'aura plus la chance
de grandir de s'accroître
devenir pleinement de voir son futur
comme partenaire égal apprécié dans la
culture québécoise
c'est vrai il ya déjà que se sont
ajustés à la loi 101 et puis il ya des
gens qui m'ont rejoint qui vont devoir
s'ajuster à cette loi si elle est
adoptée puis en tournée et on est très
loin de cette mesure au discours en
chambre le gouvernement premier de ce
projet de loi
au repos la chance mais ce projet voile
avant la fin de l'automne parce qu'avec
le moment en tout cas voilà met en vente
à choisi comme un élixir avoir parlé
ensemble aussi merci beaucoup changé
michel et attias à la prochaine pour
voir nos émissions en entier rendez vous
sur la chaîne ici et redit